hey everyone hey and welcome back to yet
another episode of watching The Watchmen
podcast this is your host Tom cui thank
you so much for joining us today we have
a very very special guest but of course
as always I'm joined by my co-host deaf
how's it going man
yeah really good really big thing for
the podcast about what happened so I'm
very excited to get into this but my
mind's rakes and what questions yeah
I'll try and try and keep it to a
minimum and you know I want to say as I
always do please subscribe to the show
leave us a review on iTunes get in touch
with us as well watching The Watchmen
pod at gmail.com if you've got any
feedback of any of our reviews or you
want any questions for us I'm gonna say
thank you to everyone who sent in
questions for today's guest as well yeah
what's on Twitter that's a new thing at
Watchmen pod but incredibly excited to
say that I've got the you know we got
the colorist from watchman mr. John
Higgins John how are you sir hi hi Tom
hi - how are you I am listening amazing
to have you on really I'm sure is
everyone listening knows that you are
you know one part of the Trivium that
created Watchmen and and many many other
things and yeah again it's greater than
the show John thank you are you more
than welcome it it gives me an
opportunity to talk about myself or
Watchmen out I'll jump to the chance
yeah kinda start enough with everything
I know you originally you began your
career and as a medical illustrator for
Royal mastan's
NHS foundation trust so how did you
really transfer into comics and art and
coloring it seems like quite a big leap
to go from one thing up to the other I
think have you been read my book by the
way cuz that's that's that's the
information in my book which is beyond
Watchmen and Judge Dredd so if people
have been looking at my book they can
check out my answers make sure I'm not
reading for the book as well well put
the links below yeah but the great thing
for me so like when I was at art college
one of the things a group of people
there aurelion to come because I'd left
him a long time in the past but I
rediscovered them mainly through
American underground comics so this is
in the mid 70s and so like to a certain
extent I wanted to get to sign
fiction book cover illustration and
really in those days because there was
no internet there was no way of
connecting with publishers upset
basically face-to-face or by phone
I needed to travel to London and I was
offered a job with the Royal Marsden
Hospital because one of the courses I
did at our college was medical
illustration so for me the opportunity
to be working in the center of the
publishing capital of Britain was a
great opportunity for me to take that
step and and it worked out obviously
perfectly yeah it's crazy really I mean
like during the mid eighties you're kind
of heralded as one of the forerunners of
the British Invasion and what was it
like at this time are there any key
things you remember or was there any
struggles kind of breaking America well
I think for me the great thing was
because when I first moved to London it
was like probably seventy seven
something like that and I think everyone
probably knows their comics history
British comics history in 2000 AD
started in 1977 so I moved to London
just for me when it was a perfect
opportunity to start looking at comics
as an alternative doing science fiction
book covers or medical illustration so
to get into comics I've started to
socialise with people who obviously if
you go to like comic shops or comic
marks you start meeting people like
minded sensibilities so I started
meeting other people like Gary leeches a
brilliant comic artists and because he
was completely focused on getting into
comics more than anything else he did
book covers as well but comics were his
forte that's where he dreamed about and
lived and breathed so mixing with like
people like Gary leach like gave me an
idea there is a possibility that there
was a job for me in in comics and I
started doing stuff for 2000ad just the
spot illustrations here and there so
mixing with like people like Gary leach
and then obviously if you started work
2008 d you start it's like seeing
obviously Brian Bolland and Dave Gibbons
in the work with Alan Moore a lot of
times so by the midday
he's I was starting to move more into
comics than in book covers science
fiction book covers
so I started sort of like mixing in
though with the people who did go first
like you know brian bondus was did
camera 3000 Denali more was writing
stuff I think Brian was probably the
first person and then as far as I know
Dave was the second person start working
full-time for American publishers so the
mid 80s was just about right for me
because one as I said it started
establishing myself in British comics
and I was starting to be employed
full-time as a comic artist rather doing
science fiction book cover so but at
that time it was a bit of everything I
was doing anything that came in
particularly you know if you're
self-employed in freelancer just wants
like work so I was doing anything the
game in I must say John I love your
cover 2084 number 43 the dial M for
monster cover you know you fantastic one
that I'm sure a lot of people are aware
of and you know where where did this
start you and Alan and Dave getting
together there was a meeting in the the
Royal Oak pub in the West End of London
was that right as one of the impetuses
for Watchmen yeah lots of great things
like you know against like one of the
things I do say when I give talks and
slike interviews it's it's probably a
lot harder now to get into comics and
and illustration generally this like the
Internet is a window you know you go
anywhere in the world to a certain
extent but there's a million other
people who want the same job with you
whereas when I first started you as I
said you had to turn up on the day with
your portfolio so it was quite small in
a way and the opportunity to go out and
see different publishers was probably
bigger in a way because nowadays most
that the British publishers I work for
the book publishers anyway they all now
are taken under transworld they're all
owned by the Penguin Books or Transworld
and there's you know in the old days the
use of your like 10 or 20 different
science fiction book publishers in
London so they were great to go to and
so people like
Holland and Dave Gibbons and those guys
we went for 2000ad I was taking on lots
of different way but because 2000ad was
all black and white or mainly black and
whites people like Dave was asking me to
do some colouring because they knew I
was doing but covered and fully painted
work so they there their interest wasn't
necessarily in the colouring side of it
and you can't select suddenly learn a
skill overnight if you were off the job
I mean one of the jobs I did with Steve
Dylan was an advertising job and we both
got really well paid you know it's like
600 pounds each should we say whereas
when you do a comic page black and white
blind so like it was only like 120
pounds so the ideas like me coming in
and helping people doing the coloring
this seemed like a logical step to
everyone who wasn't doing colouring for
themselves so talk to Dave and Alan in
particular Dave and particular day was
the person who really got me into well
into the doing the watchman I think I
can't remember if I did any work before
for America probably hadn't so probably
Dave was more than anything was the
reason I'm working for certainly working
with the American publisher in the 19
the mid nineteen eighty so yeah it's
definitely Dave and yeah so when you're
kind of talking about how you had to
learn it your coloring and I can and I
know that a lot of your work is
sometimes quite abstract and for example
in Watchmen there's lots of pages that
are like just flashes of red and I love
the way that you use color to kind of
invoke emotion as well and we noticed
out in the black fright Evers the
certain color choices there that really
are very striking and kind of unorthodox
um how do you compose the the color
palette for a book do you create one to
begin with or does it sort of evolved
with the book as it grows certainly
nowadays because the subtlety of them
computer coloring you can do anything
from you know 5% grade to 100% red and
you know and combine so many different
elements but when we did the the
Washington
because it was printed traditionally
with the old letterpress color for color
separated plates
I had to select use color in a way that
it wasn't naturalistic whereas if I was
trying to color the way most traditional
colors were doing in those days it would
have been the sky would have been blue
the grass would have been green
treatable yeah and people's faces would
have been pink I wanted to sleep when I
was at the car art college I read a book
called the psychology of perception and
they had a very large section on color
and emotional responses to color so
talking with Dave in particular and
because islanded written also island and
written about cholera from he wanted
certain scenes using certain colors so
he had to like make a combination of
sort of using color not just
decoratively but also to try and gender
some sensible emotional response to it I
mean we all know this like red is
dangerous and to a certain extent we
respond very positively when we see a
red sign or we see a red sunset even so
my thinking based on what I knew about
psychological aspect of color was to use
colorant in that way and I think I
probably was one of the I think I was
the first to use it like that in comics
anyway so kind of talking about how more
gave you ideas
he was obviously he's quite famous for
writing very grandiose notes sort of
detailing each panel did you get similar
ones for the colouring of the book or
did you have more free rein over it than
Gibbons had a turd script that dave has
published a number of times and the
detail that he had to highlight and you
know even though Alan was a stunning
writer sort of you don't necessarily
need to put all that detail in the fact
that Dave managed to put the evoke what
Alan was right and was just I never get
tired of saying
what a phenomenal combination of talent
the the Watchmen there's you know Dave
and Alan I don't think anyone's
interpret Alan as well as Dave has ever
before or since
you know evens like keV or Neil who's
being a regular collaborate with Alan
all these years I think for me Dave that
synthesis of Dave and Alan is just
mind-blowing so yeah thankfully I didn't
get that sort of detail there's only a
couple of scenes that Alan had
particularly thought about I mean when
we Rorschach is walking to morlocks
apartment he wanted a flashing neon
light because he was living in a very
sleazy sleazy part of New York and so he
wanted the foot of Rorschach to be
splashing into a pod reflecting you know
the the nightclub next door so those
little details like that he wrote about
but the color combinations I don't think
even Alan could have written so like
color combinations in a way that would
have helped me in any way
Gary loads a hex codes and stuff you
know you just would have driven me mad
and probably would have driven him even
madder than years now so and if you can
just give us a sort of layman's
breakdown of how it would work you
actually coloring some ink when you
would receive something to work on how
long you'd spend on it for Watchmen I
think for me the great thing because I
lived so close to Dave we talked about
it a lot and Slyke even if he wouldn't
select say to me I wanted to call it
this way you know was as long as it was
a key to something I could revolve
everything else around it when I decided
to use color as an emotional signpost
should you say because the the murder
scene of the comedian comes very very
soon and flashback in the first chapter
because I knew the red and the the very
striking magentas and the the Pink's
were going to be used in that way and
then we can't appointed those bright
violent colors against the flashback to
the two detectives where they were
cooler and more muted
once you have sort of like something
that's given you a key to starting off
the whole box you say which is littered
with that for me it was the comedian
with comedian once I knew I was going to
use red in that way then I was trying to
use those sort of violent colors when
there was violence scenes so that was a
key to me and then everything else then
then fell in place because if with the
funeral scene we did very muted colors
very dark sand like blues and grays and
the grass was very muted it wasn't a
bright green grass and things like that
so that's all I counterpoint was
something that made the story flow and
talking with Dave about the script
constantly you know and we met or quite
regularly probably well more than most
colors would ever meet there their
artists ever because we was socially
enjoying it so I might have met him once
or twice in the month
ron's like just meeting him when it was
colouring when it was being given the
color or when I was coloring it so to do
a page of that was actually probably
start probably a page a day of coloring
so you know it's like 28 pages I think
it was 20 pages so 28 pages would take
on with some months some pages would be
fastest on pages would take a bit longer
but as the notations for the printers
that were the biggest problem now I
don't know if you guys or your audience
have seen how those color markups had to
be supplied to the printers what we had
to write down all the individual color
percentages you know white really you
know and all that sort of stuff and that
really I hated that more than anything
and so I tend to leave that at the very
end of the the coloring job so probably
about a page your debt your half day to
do each page depending on the scene was
if I'd already set the scene because we
had lots of flashbacks so if we were
showing Rorschach in one particular
flashback or you don't showing the
comedian in a flashback
I'd already created those scenes so
either recreated or
just noted to the the printers to
actually drop in that panel so there
ways of saving time but yeah it was
quite intensive yeah can imagine this is
like sort of a more controversial
question I actually got a friend who's
been reading comics from the 50s and I
was talking to him about like the way
that things are getting reprinted now
and we've just seen that Watchmen was
being released
do y'all bar any sort of fear bad
feelings towards them just releasing a
black and white version of it because I
kind of think that it takes away from
the work itself like Watchmen is it's
very much striking yellows and reds and
purples and to have those colors muted
to me just seems like you're kind of
getting I don't know half the half the
book almost really pleased to see is I
mean I think the lovely thing is my I'm
a huge fan of Dave's work I've always
had been before we started working
together to see because I was obviously
one of the only people to see his black
and white line work before it was you
know call it up then I'm really pleased
to see you know it happen there I'm
packing it gives Dave give us a great
opportunity to warm you up every time he
waves one of the map and plus a fact I
actually keep saying to people I can
give you a set of felted pens if you
want to go and color themselves I think
so much was reading a review or you know
how many times they've repackaged The
Watchmen and some of the repackage loot
addition obviously being quite stunning
because you all got the opportunity to
digitally color it and we got rid of the
number of things that we didn't
particularly like in 1986 so the
absolute edition is the best you can get
but whether I do all these different
repackaging I have no problem with it
because the more set they sell the more
Dave and I are now on and so with that
what there was a review so like saying
you know how many different ways can you
repackage The Watchmen and it is
becoming slightly diminishing returns I
think I think the repackaging
quite stunning I think each one there's
no way one person will learn every
single republished edition of Watchmen
because it's just so many of them but
yet did the great thing for me is as
nothing lives just like you contributed
to the Washington but also as a fan of
the Watchmen and that will never have a
change because I always find something
new in us but every time I go to
conventions I'll see a new set of fans
coming with like a a new edition of
Watchmen so the fans from sleep 40-knot
and I just love that you know show
there's a new generation every couple
years is a new generation of Watchmen
fans which is brilliant yeah you must be
so incredibly proud of it because you
know me and deaf and millions of others
around the world extol how incredible
how did you feel about it being included
on Time Magazine's hundred best novels I
I think it was not a vindication to
think you know if you're a comics fan
you you understand the numbers come with
literature but I think for me it was
just brilliant to soar like for the
wider world to actually see the comics
are literature you know or can be
literature you know you have the
extremes leopold horror superhero stuff
and even that can transcend into you
know great stories but the fact that the
watchman's like straddled you know you
know murder mystery and so like
superhero emotional responses to
relationships was just it was just
really to be recognized as I was just
blown away by that yeah that's really by
intrigue in just how well it's kind of
transcended the genre I mean kind of
tying into that I saw an interview on
the Victoria gallery where he discussed
how there's no real difference now
between fine art and popular modern art
do you think that the lines are being
blurred across the board due to
adaptation so for example superhero
comics are now kind of bleeding into
movies and TVs and I mean a lot of
movies could be viewed as a piece of art
like I watched Blade Runner 2049 today
and I was just I just think it's
incredible and do you think there's like
is still a clear division between media
or is it all part of one collective of
like creative consciousness
I did go to different sorts of
conventions I go to science fiction
conventions and likely come to
conventions in particular book it's
amazing how some people's perceptions
like a lot of science fiction
there is a crossover in science fiction
and the comic what you do find there's a
hard core of science fiction readers RSS
readers you say who really turn the nose
or puts like you know the low the lowest
so like add you have so like what come
to about you know so that I think people
would just automatically just dismiss
them and not give them a chance at all
but it's like people of intelligence
perception and depth like we are and all
our listeners you know we know like the
there's no crossover anymore so like
great science fiction great comics even
greats like superhero you know movies by
Marvel's like you know they're just
entertaining and suddenly can cross over
into ass I mean as you say it's like you
know the latest Blade Runner
you know blade one is my number one
movie of all time you know it's all of
you in my top ten that's always been
number one and Blade Runner
20:49 is just very close second now it's
just so good it's pure art I mean the
the director was that was so like saying
for some reason it wasn't as massive as
successes I believe it should have been
probably you believe it should have been
here was did the director was saying in
in fear and Empire Magazine that he made
the most expensive art house movie ever
you know it's just brilliant so yeah I
mean I think there's the culture is away
now because through the internet I mean
people can pick and choose whereas in
the past when I first came into science
fiction or comics we felt part of the
cult you know and you know we felt part
of its its cult entertainment or cold
literature now it's like it's worldwide
we can find we just click on we find
thousands probably millions of other
people who love something very similar
what we do whenever I go to
international conventions around the
world the thing that I love most is like
seeing what the homegrown comes are
about and sadly in one ways like a lot
of it is their version of American soo
/ heroes fish I find slightly slightly
depressing but you know the its it's in
way comics now is an international
language I'm blessed to be part of that
way
and speaking of cinema of course there
was the watchman film and did you have
any involvement in that at all no it's
like Dave asked me if I once Lee come on
and get involved with talk about the
empress' interviews and stuff like that
because he's such an incredibly generous
collaborator and friend and where I had
no real interest in that and this is
probably 2009 I think when it came out
was it 2009 2009 yeah yeah so I just
like they were doing with promotion and
pre publicity it's like a year or so
before and I really wasn't up to public
speaking in those days I mean 10 years
obviously almost 10 years of past now
I'm a bit more useful for one reason or
another obviously I do quite a bit more
now but what I enjoyed and I still enjoy
is like you do drawing and telling
stories and that's what my driving force
is Mike driving creativity and Dave is
so like almost transcended his roots as
a comic artist you know who's made
comics laureate last yeah yeah a couple
of years ago I think he was I think
Charlie Adlard was last year's and say
Dave was the first one and that was me
that was Anna issued commissioned or you
know he was crowned the laureate in the
lakes
2016 maybe I forgot what year is his by
anyway yes he so he's doing a lot of
promotion through comics and to certain
extent because of Kingsman as well he is
he's gone from Washington success on to
lots of other successful and Kingsman in
a way is probably one of the most
commercial successful things he's done
with Mark Miller so there's an extent he
he's almost transcended his roots as I
said so you know he's it doesn't
necessarily need to work I still need to
work so yeah and then like Watchmen sort
of transcended its roots now a bit and
with Doomsday Clock
one of my big criticisms of that is that
the color it sort of colored to look for
a realistic and but obviously a lot of
people prefer that style now do you
prefer like the more pulp coloring in
comic books or is the the realistic
color palette more what you aim for now
most naturalistic colors now I think
just yeah
because my partner my wife she's now my
colorist so I tend to do the black and
white line and yeah I mix I give her so
the color advice but she tends to be my
colorist now so Sally Joep this is my
colorist which seems weird because
probably more people know me in the
world for coloring the Watchmen and The
Killing Joke than doings like all the
thousands of pages of Judge Dredd line
art have done but yeah so the sort of
stuff that we do now tends to be quite
muted and quite realistic because that
tends to be modern style at the moment
I'm actually like doing probably my
favorite job well exactly my favorite
job in a very long time because last
year we spent more or less just
promoting the exhibition in Liverpool
which is just finished this year Museum
and I think you've just been you went to
Tom I I know I haven't seen it actually
no I went to the University of Liverpool
myself but I I mixed that what I'd love
to have gone yeah well I was blown away
by how they presented it and going back
to the interview you saw me doing with
the University was the fact that what
the curator did likely only said and who
is the curator she so like looked at how
to present it in a way that's like you
know fitted the gallery and it's a fine
art gallery the Victoria gallery Museum
in Liverpool is one of the best
galleries I believe in in Britain and to
be shown there she was a crowning world
in my career but I did very very little
work you know paid where Jewish legs
like did my job which is drawing comics
were living and telling stories and I
spent a lot of time doing workshops and
presentations and stuff
which is brilliant because my hometown
but on coming back now which is what
I've done now I've been working non-stop
for the you know it finished in February
the exhibition and since it's February
now isn't still yes that yeah yeah just
about
that's right yes well I went off for the
last time at the beginning of February
when I finished but before that the last
workshop we did was probably October at
so anyway I've been working on stuff
about three months on the latest thing
I'm doing for 2000ad magazine which is
Judge Dredd and Razor Jack my characters
called razor Jack and off.you Judge
Dredd had won those to read and we're
doing a crossover with Mike out and my
favorite character which is Judge Dredd
so at the moment we just haven't so much
fun and the thing that I'm enjoying
about this is I'm calling a lot more of
this with Sally we're doing a really
tight crossover and this was the last
job we did which was the mm II was grey
suit and that was very muted and very
realistic because Judge Dredd is science
fiction pure science fiction and raised
Jack is science fiction as well I'm
allowed to go to town on the colors and
I that's the thing I love about science
fiction away because you can make it
whatever you want it doesn't have to be
naturalistic so I definitely recommend
everyone to pick it up in May when it
comes out we're just right in the middle
of it as a moment
so the calling we're doing for that is
quite striking and very very science
fiction issue suppose and that's
probably all I went into science fiction
anyway because I love those sort of
covers colors yeah for me I don't you
guys you way too young to remember Bruce
Pennington maybe or Bruce Pennington as
well as the best science fiction artists
next to Chris Foss in Britain in the
world as far as I could but his colors
were just so striking and so visually
you know an immediate impact you could
see the book cover across the bookstore
soon as you walked in so that's where I
came from I came from slightly using :
weights like one attract attention but
also to get in motion sponge so I'll use
what I was required rolling yeah and
kind of gone back to their The Killing
Joke that you mentioned there and we
actually analyzed
the book for our mid-season break and we
kind of went into it like one of the big
controversial aspects of it is the
recoloring I did actually say you're on
the podcast that I actually prefer the
original colorin and I mean I'm not I'm
not just kissing your ass it's been I've
recorded it down and I think it kind of
adds to the zany characterizations a lot
more and without kind of digging up too
much they are throwing anyone under the
bus how does the recoloring sit with you
and did you pick it up or do you just
kind of think oh really is someone's
just doing a different take on my own
work it's as you said the thing it was a
bit of a surprise to me because when I
walked into my local bookstore when I
first the recolored Edition came out you
know you just looked at all the graphic
novels and one of the pleasures for me
was my name underneath Allen and Brian's
you know John Higgins color sort well
John Higgins with the three of us there
and I went in and didn't see my name up
there heck's going on here or words to
that effect and looked inside and
obviously it was all muted and modern
issue we say and it's not by coloring so
it does not mean anything to me it's I
don't fault Brian for doing it because
he wants to do it originally but because
he was so slow I was brought into the
mix because they want to get the book
out and published you know when's like
I'm Alan was hearts and Brian was you
know taking so long to do the line
artwork and and as beautiful as it is
you know the bottom line is you need
something to be published before people
can appreciate how good it is
to do my coloring job because I just
finished Watchmen you know I knew how to
produce an emotional response from the
coloring I was trying to do and because
the killing jar I read the killings
cuz being from the Joker's perspective
you know I felt this like it was a joke
who is like driving the whole story and
you know it was his story even those
like the Dark Knight
you know he's the the well the main
character should we say sending the hero
that we all root for so ice like I call
it it the one I perceived the way would
be in plus fact him you can't do a new
to graze like fairground surely you know
so anyway other things for me dictated
the way I approach the coloring and what
I'd learned on Watchmen to get an
emotional response from the reader was
to use those sort of colors I didn't
really read what was being said about it
or thank you for saying what you just
say Tom and I don't necessarily listen
to what people were saying about its
online because it was a job I did you
know 20 odd years ago thirty odd years
ago but I've just written an article
about it was asked to write my version
of waking at that time and I did a bit
of research on online just to see what
other people said and I read a couple of
very nice things about what people
appreciated about my clothing rather
than what Brian had done to his coming
so um I feel you know if you split
people 50/50 that's fine if it splits
people more to me that's fine well I
don't really mind either way I mean I
think the great thing is you you have
the opportunity to like see Brian's
approach from the dark monk you know
from the Joker's perspective so I think
it's just incredible I can't wait to see
them combine it one day in the absolute
edition yeah yeah yet suppose that is
quite mad oh really because the Joker
talks about how his pastor sort of
multiple choice and now you kind of have
a multiple choice and for the colors of
the book yeah that's very nice that's
what we do here John will close up a few
quick emails that we've gotten from some
fans so I'm first of all from Eric
Ferguson
who's a great fan of the show always
sending in some excellent emails um his
first question before you John was
whose choice was it to make Ozymandias
his costume purple it was an instant
giveaway that he was the villain as only
villains use purple all right thanks
Eric I appreciate that question and the
nice thing is I can blame Dave Gibbons
for that when we sat down and talked
about what we wanted Dave did have an
idea of a number of things that he did
what he knew Rorschach's coloring Mowgli
[Music]
Knight ow and yeah you wanted the the
gold and the purple like royalty
particularly because not necessarily Oz
Amanda's sort of like he was talking
about you know paths Alexander the Great
and royalty and stuff so there was that
combinations like anything's you know
obviously he had feelings of grandeur
should we say you want to save the world
so the royalty aspect and the purple
came together as opposed so I didn't
necessarily think it was a finger
pointing as a villain but yet he turned
out to be the villain yeah and is there
anything again Eric asking here is this
something that you've added to Watchmen
that's not commonly known actually one
of the things in my book which I have
pointed out in detail the dope for me
it's like the exhibition liberal gave me
the opportunity to do an
autobiographical are poor and I got the
opportunity to sleep put my point of
view from my perspective completely
nothing you know no one else no editing
or anything so if you want to read the
ins and outs if you go for my book which
I'm turning around because I currently
memoirs cold brisk be on Watchmen and
Judge Dredd the art of John Higgins with
a foreword by Dave Gibbons so obviously
we're still friends but my go in detail
and there there's a couple of things in
there that I point out that I did in
Watchmen there I think I find
interesting I don't know if we have time
to talk about now but when the hand
separators in those days had to do a
certain effect they use their thumb
prints and I when we did the absolute
addition I could have done a complete
airbrush effect and very smooth
digitally but I actually recreated what
we originally did in 1986 just because I
was so proud of those unsung heroes who
hand cept all the colors for the
original printing so that's something
that you should look out for
and that's when dr. Manhattan comes back
as dr. Manhattan for the first time if
you look at the glow around tomb you see
thing fingerprints oh wow yeah so if you
look in the absolute edition and if you
look in the original edition in the
absolute position they're my
fingerprints if you look in the original
edition it's someone known handset
country in America somewhere so yeah
yeah and that's question from Eric he
says that Alan Moore has said something
to the effect that the medium of comics
is great but much of the writing leaves
something to be desired
where does coloring need to go or go to
achieve or go to achieve in the medium
where do you want to see it go
I actually think with digital coloring
now we can do anything you want me to
like do water call effects fully painted
effects oil paint fax or we do airbrush
effects which to think that I always
wants to do so I think we've actually
achieved with color probably a lot of
what everyone else is still striving for
in comics and the bottom line is this
always in the eye of the beholder to
certain extent an individual artist will
have their key signature that will
people really love or hate and you know
that's the the meeting we have which i
think is just brilliant you know people
will appreciate what you do because you
bring something new into the mix I think
you're right is a lot harder because
it's easier to George art dance like you
know look at a script or to read a comic
book
you know you sometimes they have to play
the the mean games like in the middle
let's try not to alienate people the
great thing about people like Alan Moore
and Mark Miller a lot of other British
writers and Frank Miller when he was
doing it to the height of his abilities
you know these people take risks and I
think sometimes certainly was the main
publishers Martha
DC I probably think Marvel and more to
blame than DC at this but they tend to
play safe and particularly now they've
brought out by Disney it's it's like
getting quite bland now you know
particularly kind of dumping mark is
right for them anymore and Michael
Bendis has come to DC so yeah you know I
think it's up to the writers to lift
their game well I think the opportunity
at the mouth would be with digital in
particular I mean even if people are
inking digitally we can do some really
fascinating stuff now digitally so
timely comics last question last email
from mark Andrew Nordstrom who's been
getting in touch with the show a lot as
well and you sort of touched on this
with Watchmen noir but question for
Johnny says what was your experience
with the Zender French edition of The
Watchmen cover prince's signature plates
considering the French covers as black
and white
do you enjoy seeing them that way or
does it feel naked about the life that
your colors add like with the I mean I
just love Dave's artwork I mean I got
the opportunity to recolor the black
place a Dave did specially for the
advertising promotion you know before
watch we came out and think they were
for the Americans you know I think they
did I think they just black-and-white
ads in regular comic yeah you know what
came out and Daved an incredible series
of quite very mature and very sort of
like teaser sort of illustration so I
got the opportunity to color them when I
was great opportunity for me to do that
but I just look Dave's artwork I mean
when he was doing Watchmen it was just
when everything came - I think for me
everything came together with Dave he
had the enthusiasm the energy and the
ability to do that sort of artwork and
like I can't believe anyone would
actually have done it any better than he
could have done it so I'm just a huge
fan of seeing this black and white line
work so I'm quite a producer look at
this black and white line yeah what a
patriot am very happy to cover and I
have interest um Alan Moore have you
speak to him it's always been doing
recently like like we Dave or no I
haven't spoke we saw him about two years
ago I think really matter now intensely
really leave their Northampton air
anymore yeah I think he does do signing
still in orbital but I think there's
very few places he goes out to so yeah I
haven't seen for about two years mr.
shame yeah very interesting
even now I loved it in the early days
when we just used to go around get drink
and substances maybe I'm yet a just
great fun who's just building one you we
all you guys probably the same when you
first start out you just mix and if you
want to mix with and the sky's the limit
any any closing questions death no no I
have been a brilliant brilliant man I so
really enjoyed it yeah yeah thank you
anything you want to promote or John can
you pick a couple of times your website
is there anything people should check
out internal links or no just check out
the art of John Higgins calm other than
that it's just really nice to talk to
you guys thank you very much for having
me on Louis absolute pleasure Frank
Tehran for listening as well yeah John
this is Ben this has been a treat you
know you've created something that me
and deaf you know boys and millions of
people around the world so just again
thank you so much John you're more than
welcome
thanks Jeff thanks Tom thank you dude
again
you